with the Christmas period well and truly
upon us it seems like a good time to
explore some of the weirdest Christmas
traditions around the world
[Music]
one of the most amusing traditions that
I've come across can be found in the
Catalan region of Spain and features
Theodore Nadal the Christmas log
sometimes referred to as the poop log
because of its poop like appearance I
guess the process begins when a branch
from the Yule tree is hollowed out and
the character is created complete with
legs smiley face and even a floppy red
hat the tradition begins on the 8th of
December when families bring out the
smile in log every night until Christmas
Eve the children are given the task of
feeding the log by filling it up with
nuts dried fruits and sweets once the
children are done they then cover the
log with a blanket to keep it warm on
Christmas Eve the families gather around
the log and proceed to beat the log of
sticks while they sing traditional songs
when the blanket is removed it appears
as if the log has pooped out a part of
sweets and presents for all of the
family once this process is complete the
poop log is then thrown into the fire
and the logs last Christmas gift is the
gift of warmth in Norway they believe
that Christmas Eve coincides of the
arrival of evil spirits and witches with
brooms being the preferred method of
transportation for most witches it seems
reasonable to hide all your brooms right
we can assume now that we're vacuum
cleaners being part of most households
the tradition of hiding your broom
sticks before you go to sleep may not be
as popular as it once was whilst on the
topic of evil spirits and mischievous
creatures we travel to Greece where the
callee cancellous make an appearance at
this time of year in many countries
around the world and in Greek folklore
the Kali cancerous are a race of
malevolent goblins that dwell
underground
on Christmas Day they make their way to
the surface where they remain for the 12
days of Christmas until January 6th when
they return to their home they often
described as small dark creatures who've
a long black tail their diet consists of
mainly small critters such as worms
snails and frogs their fear of the Sun
means that they only come out of hiding
during the evening and can be seen
climbing through windows and down
chimneys once inside a household they do
tend to cause havoc it became common for
families to place a colander on their
doorstep in order to keep them away
these goblins were believed to be rather
stupid and they could only count to two
meaning they would spend all night
counting the holes in the colander other
methods of protection involved placing
the black cross on your door and burning
the shoe as the smell will keep them
away overall they are not particularly
dangerous but they are mischievous and
rather troublesome
now when it comes to decorate in a
Christmas tree in Ukraine it's tradition
to use artificial spiders and webs
rather than tinsel and baubles the roots
of this tradition can be found in the
story of the spider in the Christmas
tree the story is about a family who
grew a pine tree for Christmas but
unfortunately they were too poor to
afford decorations
these spiders that lived in the family's
Hut heard the children crying before
they went to bed about how bad the
Christmas tree was and so the spiders
decided that they would create beautiful
silk webs to decorate the tree with when
the children are woke on Christmas
morning they were delighted with their
newly decorated tree and from that day
on the family never considered
themselves poor they were extremely
grateful of the gift they had been given
in Ukraine spiderwebs are believed to
give good fortune for the upcoming year
on the topic of strange decorations
there were some German families who
would hide a pickle in their Christmas
tree on Christmas Eve the first child to
discover it on Christmas Day
would be rewarded with a gift in South
Africa they do have some rather interest
in traditions when most people are
enjoying a traditional Christmas dinner
the locals prefer to tuck into some deep
fried caterpillars not exactly a meal
for those of you who are squeamish
children in South Africa told a chilling
story about a young boy named Danny on
Christmas Eve Danny's grandmother left
cookies out for Santa and once she had
gone to bed
Danny snuck downstairs and ate all of
the cookies when his grandmother found
out she was furious and in her rage she
killed Danny
he's ghost is said to haunt the homes of
misbehaving children around Christmas
the Krampus schlaf of the Krampus run is
something that we've discussed before
and takes place in Austria and several
other Bavarian countries adults dress up
as the demon Krampus and walk through
town scaring children almost like a
Halloween but where the roles are
reversed the adults are the ones now
dressing up and scaring the children
into behaving
in some parts of Italy they do not wait
for the arrival of Santa instead la
Befana often referred to as the good
which much like Santa Claus she hands
out gifts and presents to children
around Christmastime there are weird and
fun traditions all around the world and
if you know of any or even partake in
any traditions that I haven't mentioned
feel free to let me know in the comments
below as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained
[Music]
you